september has already been quite a month
for game pass not only have we already
seen 13 new games there's still an
additional eight on the way but don't
worry there's a lot to cover but we're
going to go over all of it from what's
new from what's on the way and the staff
pick of a game that maybe you should
consider checking out welcome to your
game pass digest for the entire month of
september i'm kurt devina
and let's get on with it
here's what's available right now
craftopia it's like if breath of the
wild stepped into a teleportation
machine and a fly-sized harvest moon got
trapped in there with it and then on the
other side came out craftopia a
multiplayer survival action game
final fantasy xiii yeah this one's kind
of an oldie but look all the final
fantasies age like a fine cheese even
when it molds over time it's still
somehow forgivable considering it's
off-putting scent but still great to
chow down on
[Music]
signs of the sojourner it's a narrative
card game where each conversation uses a
hand of cards to interweave a
conversation together which is actually
like kind of deep because aren't we all
just playing life with a handful of
cards dealt to us at the beginning
anyways this game is cool and it's a
good balance of being narrative heavy
while still engaging the player in
interesting ways
if you've ever considered exploring a
career and being a surgeon but don't
want to go through years of school and a
lifetime of loans then just play surgeon
simulator 2 where you'll learn
everything you need to know about
becoming a pro surgeon and it also has
multiplayer because you know how the
saying goes performing open heart
surgery is always more fun with a crowd
[Music]
crown trick it's a churn-based roguelike
set in the dungeony nightmare realm
harness the crown master the dungeon and
take on a couple giant witches damn look
at that fish these nightmares actually
seem cool in mine i'm just usually late
to work and can't find the bathroom this
seems way cooler
breath edge hailed as an ironic outer
space survival adventure game it's not
your mission to save the galaxies or to
fend off an unknown life form but
deliver your grandpa's ashes to a
galactic funeral that is until you get
wrapped up in some universal conspiracy
new clear throne it's a twin stick
bullet held pixel art roguelike shooter
set in a post-apocalyptic world this is
an endeared modern classic to many so if
you've been sleeping on it well this is
your moment to shine and get radiated
the artful escape play as a qatar
prodigy on a multi-dimensional journey
to confront the legacy of a dead musical
legend and in the process inspire your
own stage persona the artful escape is
also a console exclusive to xbox and
features voice talent from none other
than carl weathers sign
me up
flynn son of crimson a pixel art 2d
action platformer that'll have you
riding this fluffy and vicious but still
adorable mythical companion you'll be
slashing dashing and hopping through a
slew of environments while on a journey
through conflict and discovery
[Music]
i am fish you play as fish separated
from one another at a pet shop who must
be brought back together there's fish
that swim fish that fly fish that roll
fish that chump and you'll be playing it
the whole time saying i
am fish because that's where you are in
iron
[Music]
fish but maybe in your heart you know
you're not a fish you don't swim in the
depths no you soar in the sky like a
hawk but you also skateboard so you're
more like tony hawk except you're not
actually a hawk you're a chickadee but
still on the skateboard in fact you're
skatebird and if you hear me saying this
and you're like yeah i'm all those
things then skateboard is the game for
you you'll be playing it the whole time
saying i am skatebird
super liminal is what we perceive
actually reality or is it all just a
facade super limo takes this to the nth
degree in a puzzle game that'll have you
thinking beyond perception itself to
solve mind-boggling optical illusion
puzzles none of it makes sense and yet
it all does
origami too you like ninjas you like
stealthing around you like skill-based
combat if you answered yes to all the
above then maybe just maybe you should
consider checking out origami 2. defend
the origami clan from invading armies
stealth around on your own or with a
friend because it's co-op and look
really cool doing it
now all the games i just listed off are
available today to play but we still
have one more week left in this month
until we head off into spooky town of
october so let's go over what you can
expect over the next week
lost worlds beyond the page
sable
subnautica below zero
tainted grail conquest
alumni's gate
astria ascendant
unsighted
and phoenix point
as you can tell there are a lot of
choices so in this segment we hand it
off to another member of gamespot to
tell you their staff pick to maybe help
you with this cumbersome library of game
pass games and pick a hidden gem that
you may have not considered playing
before so for this particular staff pick
i am tossing it over to the other side
of the world to the uk to none other
than chris morris take it away hi i'm
chris and the game pass game i want you
to check out is planet coaster console
edition i grew up playing the roller
coaster tycoon games spending hours
pouring over every inch of my park
building my dream roller coasters and
making sure every ride had immaculate
scenery and planet coaster is the
spiritual successor to those games and
is an absolute joy to play the original
game may have been released on pc back
in 2016 but the game has a kind of
charming art style that wears those five
years extremely well there's a campaign
mode and the imagination playground of
sandbox mode plus purpose-built
tutorials for console players there are
some limits on how much you can build
but they usually only kick in when your
part gets really big or really detailed
now i know what you're thinking surely
the controls are terrible but wait
frontier clearly puts a huge amount of
effort into making sure that it works
smoothly with a gamepad and they've
changed up the menus and interface to
make sure it plays well on a tv it may
take a little while to get used to but i
swear after a few hours i actually
preferred using a game pad to design
coasters from the comfort of my sofa
i can spend hours tweaking every little
detail of my park and that's the secret
of planet coaster it's a game that's all
about letting your creative dreams run
wild how many games do you play nowadays
where your only job is to make hundreds
of people as happy and excited as
possible it's an antidote to 99
of all other games and it's well worth
checking out on game pass
there you have it your game pass digest
for september there's a whole bunch of
games but hopefully we helped narrow it
down for you or make it worse who knows
there's a lot of interesting things and
so little time in the world but hey
what a time to be alive if you found
this video helpful make sure to give us
a thumbs up it would be greatly
appreciated and if you're not already
consider subscribing because
we talk about games a lot that's all we
talk about is games and if you're here
it's it's because of video games
assumably alright one more time i'm
current divina see you next time and
have fun
[Music]
you